We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Trying to succinctly sum up the character or purpose of any city in the world is probably a fruitless exercise. But for much of its history, Bond Germany was particularly... The first word that comes to mind is quiet.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持。该大学是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“99%看不见”。我是罗曼·马斯。试图简洁地总结世界上任何一个城市的性格或宗旨可能都是徒劳的。但在其历史的大部分时间里，德国波恩特别……脑海中浮现的第一个词就是安静。
Unremarkable. Bond is just a quiet town. Kind of hard to pin down. We got hills on one side, the river on the other side. Generally, it's just a sleepy, quiet, you know, even quaint little town. That's Sarouc Farr of R, and he works for the German International Broadcaster, Deutsche Vela, and he lives in Bonn. Bonn has just over 300,000 people, it's on the Rhine River, so it was strategically
平凡无奇。波恩只是一个安静的小镇。有点难以琢磨。一边是群山，另一边是河流。总的来说，它只是一个沉睡的、安静的，你知道的，甚至古色古香的小镇。这是来自德国国际广播电台（德国之声）的萨鲁克·法尔，他住在波恩。波恩拥有三十多万人口，坐落在莱茵河畔，因此它在战略上具有重要意义
important during World War II. And let's not forget Beethoven was born there in 1770. But he took off in his early 20s for the burgeoning musical capital of Vienna. Not much happened in Bonn until the end of World War II, when Bonn was named as the Provisional Capital of West Germany, it became a city with a purpose. It was the government's seat. And then, a half a century later, the country was reunified, the Berlin Wall came down, and Germany decided to move the capital away from Bonn and back to Berlin. Now, over a decade after its move, Bonn is trying to forge its own identity.
在二战期间非常重要。别忘了贝多芬于1770年出生在那里。但他在20出头时就动身前往蓬勃发展的音乐之都维也纳。在二战结束之前，波恩并没有发生太多事情。二战结束后，波恩被指定为西德的临时首都，它成了一个有使命的城市。它是政府所在地。然后，半个世纪后，国家重新统一，柏林墙倒塌，德国决定将首都从波恩迁回柏林。现在，在迁都十多年后，波恩正在努力塑造自己的身份。
This is what Saroosa Street sounds like at 9 a.m. on a weekday. He actually lives in what was once the old diplomatic quarter of Bonn, former home to many embassies and ambassadors' residences. It's pretty quiet. It's pretty quiet. But it turns out that for newcomers like me, it's not immediately obvious where the embassies used to be.
这就是周工作日上午9点萨鲁克所在的街道的声音。他实际上住在波恩曾经的外交区，这里曾是许多大使馆和大使官邸的所在地。这里非常安静。非常安静。但事实证明，对于像我这样初来乍到的外人来说，大使馆以前在哪里并不是一眼就能看出来的。
But according to Mikhail Venshal, a local journalist who grew up in the neighborhood and wrote a book about Bond's diplomatic history, there is one thing that you can look for to clue you in as to where the embassies used to be. Flagpole. Flagpole. Flagpole. Flagpole. Flagpole.
但据米哈伊尔·文沙尔（Mikhail Venshal）所说，他是一名当地记者，在这个街区长大，并写过一本关于波恩外交史的书，有一件事你可以寻找，它能给你提供以前大使馆所在地的线索。旗杆。旗杆。旗杆。旗杆。旗杆。
Flagpole. With no flag this house was for example the embassy of Lebanon michael had a tough time remembering the english word flagpole but today when you see a flag a pole
旗杆。没有国旗。这栋房子例如曾经是黎巴嫩大使馆。迈克尔很难想起英语单词“flagpole”，但今天当你看到一面旗、一根杆
oh my god when you see a flagpole without flag i think an 80 80% sign for former Amazon. For former Amazon. Because you have no other signs. Michele explained to me that half a century before World War II, this part of bond was founded as a small summer retreat
哦，天哪，当你看到一根没有旗帜的旗杆时，我认为有80%的迹象表明它曾是大使馆。因为你没有别的标志。米歇尔向我解释说，在二战前前半个世纪，波恩的这一地区被建立为一个小型避暑胜地
for the wealthy. In fact, this specific part of bond is is known as Badgotisberg, and this specific part of Badgotisberg is called the Philanthiertel, the Villa Quarter. Down closer to the Rhine, Michal pointed out the former British ambassador's residence. When the Union Jack was flying over this building, you said there was a certain feeling about it. Yes, it was a feeling of you know, Union Jack, stars and stripes, a feeling of the end of World War II. So peace basically. Peace, no peace. Something important. Union Jack here on the Rhine, it was a symbol.
专为富人而设。事实上，波恩的这个特定部分被称为巴德戈德斯贝格（Bad Godesberg），而巴德戈德斯贝格的这个特定部分被称为别墅区（Viertel）。再往靠近莱茵河的地方，米哈伊尔指出了前英国大使官邸。当米字旗在这栋建筑上飘扬时，你说过有一种特殊的感觉。是的，那是一种感觉，你知道的，米字旗，星条旗，一种二战结束的感觉。所以基本上是和平。和平，不和平。一些重要的事情。莱茵河畔的米字旗，它是一个象征。
It was a symbol. American forces took Bohn in 1945, not long before the end of the war. After the war ended, Germany was carved up into various zones of occupation, and Bohn was firmly in the British zone. In 1949, Bohn became the provisional capital of West Germany. The choice was made mainly due to the advocacy of West Germany's first chancellor, Conrad Adenauer. He was a former mayor of Cologne and a native of the area. But Bond was also an appealing choice as the capital city because it was a small town
它是一个象征。美军于1945年攻占波恩，不久后战争结束。战争结束后，德国被划分为不同的占领区，波恩稳固地处在英占区。1949年，波恩成为西德的临时首都。之所以做出这个选择，主要是因为西德第一任总理康拉德·阿登纳的倡导。他是科隆的前市长，也是当地人。但波恩作为首都也是一个有吸引力的选择，因为它是一个小镇
relatively intact, and it didn't really have a character. Choosing Bon was choosing provisionality. Berlin was out of the question, of course, the Nazis had set up shop there before. Frankfurt and Hamburg were the wrong choice because they were too big and would have felt too permanent. Bon was a clean slate. Little Sleepy Bon was still the subject of some ridicule. A 1986 Los Angeles Times article, Profiling Bond, had a few good one-line zingers about the city. Ignat's Kieshla, the Minister of Agriculture, is fond of saying that the best thing about Bond
相对完好，而且并没有真正的个性。选择波恩就是选择临时性。柏林当然是不可能的，纳粹之前就在那里设立过据点。法兰克福和汉堡不是正确的选择，因为它们太大了，会让人觉得过于永久。波恩是一张白纸。沉睡的小波恩仍然遭受一些嘲笑。1986年《洛杉矶时报》的一篇文章在报道波恩时，对这个城市有一些精彩的单行讽刺。农业部长伊格纳茨·基施拉（Ignaz Kiesle）喜欢说，波恩最好的地方
is the train to Munich. Former Chancellor Helmut Schmidt called Bond a collection of crippled villages. He spent most weekends in his native Hamburg. An American correspondent based in Bond said it was half the size of a Chicago cemetery and twice his dead. But you shouldn't feel too bad for bond. It struck it big is the capital. Bond got tons of cash.
就是去慕尼黑的火车。前总理赫尔穆特·施密特称波恩是“残缺村庄的集合”。他大部分周末都在他的家乡汉堡度过。常驻波恩的一位美国记者说，它只有芝加哥公墓的一半大，死气沉沉的程度却是两倍。但你不必对波恩感到太遗憾。它作为首都发了一大笔财。波恩获得了大量的资金。
The city built a subway, an international school, an opera house, all of this in a city of just around 300,000 people. But then, the impossible happened. The Cold War ended. Germany reunified and the Berlin Wall came down. And the German parliament voted to move the capital back to Berlin. A June of 91 when the decision failed to go to Berlin. Here in Bonnet was a shock for all people. We said each other, all the things were left to Berlin,
这座城市修建了地铁、一所国际学校、一座歌剧院，所有这些都建造在一个只有大约三十万人口的城市里。但随后，不可思议的事情发生了。冷战结束了。德国重新统一，柏林墙倒塌。德国议会投票决定将首都迁回柏林。1991年6月，当决定迁往柏林时。这里的波恩对所有人来说都是一个震惊。我们互相说道，所有的事情都留给了柏林，
and Bonnet was terrible this moment. In other words, everyone thought Bonn would lose its mojo at best and at worst would become a ghost town. The parliament decided that by 1999, nearly all government ministries would move back to Berlin, and that of course included the embassies, as all the action was now in Berlin. Today the former French embassy in Bonn is the physical embodiment of all the fears that people had about what Bonn would be like once the capital moved away. A ghost town. Do you see this building?
而波恩在这一刻糟糕透顶。换句话说，每个人都认为波恩往好里说会失去它的魔力，往坏里说会变成一座鬼城。议会决定到1999年，几乎所有的政府部委都将搬回柏林，当然这也包括大使馆，因为现在所有的行动都在柏林。今天，波恩的前法国大使馆是人们对波恩在首都迁走后会变成什么样子的所有恐惧的实体化。一座鬼城。你看到这座建筑了吗？
It was the embassy of France. And France sold it... It looks terrible. It's a ruin. Yeah, it looks like there's graffiti, there's broken glass, there's there's vines growing everywhere. Just to further paint the image of this old French embassy today, there are like 30-foot high bushes in the front of the building, there's broken glass and graffiti everywhere. You can see all of this on Google Street View. And you might think that this would be the case for all of the former embassies in Bonn. But actually, what happened was that some of the embassies
它是法国大使馆。法国把它卖了……看起来糟糕透了。它成了一片废墟。是的，看起来有涂鸦，有碎玻璃，到处都长满了藤蔓。为了进一步描绘这座今天的老法国大使馆的形象，建筑前面大约有30英尺高的灌木丛，到处都是碎玻璃和涂鸦。你可以在谷歌街景上看到这一切。你可能会认为波恩所有的前大使馆都是这种情况。但实际上，发生的事情是，一些大使馆
got turned into consulates. Others got sold and turned it to private homes. And many actually still have empty flag poles out front. But the important thing is that Bonn is not a ghost town. It turns out that moving the capital to Berlin might just be the best thing for the city And 20 years later we see that it was a very good decision and Uberschriftner, the newspapers, boom-town-born. It was an historical change.
变成了领事馆。其他的被卖掉并改造成了私人住宅。许多大使馆实际上在正门前仍然竖立着空旷的旗杆。但重要的是，波恩并不是一座鬼城。事实证明，将首都迁往柏林可能对这座城市来说是最好的事情。20年后的今天，我们看到这是一个非常好的决定，正如报纸大标题所说，“繁荣的波恩”。这是一个历史性的变化。
This house, this buildings were occupied by many countries about 30, 40, 50 years. The country's left and the houses, buildings, offices became new owners. The first thing that the owners did was to renovate this houses. It's wonderful. And today, what makes Bonn so attractive for lots of people, including newly privatized major companies like Deutsche Post and Deutsche Telekom, is that all of that infrastructure that bond lucked into getting when it was the capital of West Germany, the subway, the international school, you know, that all that stuff, that's what now makes bond such a nice
这栋房子，这些建筑被许多国家占领了大约30、40、50年。国家离开了，房屋、建筑、办公室迎来了新的主人。业主们做的第一件事就是翻新这些房子。这太棒了。今天，是什么让波恩对许多人如此具有吸引力，包括新私有化的大公司，如德国邮政（Deutsche Post）和德国电信（Deutsche Telekom），是因为波恩在作为西德首都时意外获得的那些基础设施，地铁、国际学校，你知道，所有这些东西，正是这些东西现在让波恩成为一个如此美好
place to live. And unlike the old and new capital of Berlin, bond has had both job and population growth over the last 10 years. Becoming the capital put bond on the map. But today to quote bond's own mayor from an article in the New York Times, bond is no longer a boring bureaucrat city. It's now able to figure out what it wants to be on its own. bureaucrat city. It's now able to figure out what it wants to be on its own. And maybe someday we'll even take down all those empty flag pools. Or how about this?
适合居住的地方。与新老首都柏林不同，波恩在过去10年中实现了就业和人口的双增长。成为首都让波恩名声大噪。但今天，借用《纽约时报》一篇文章中波恩自己的市长的话来说，波恩不再是一个无聊的官僚城市。它现在能够自己弄清楚它想成为什么样的人。也许有一天我们甚至会撤下所有那些空旷的旗杆。或者这样如何？
Put up a flag. The German flag is nice. The city of Bonn has a nice flag too. There's a strong lion and a cross. Someone call him like small the law of legends. 99% in visible was produced this week by Sirou Svaravar and me Roman Mars, with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, go to the website. It's 99%Invisible.org. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, It's wonderful. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
升起一面旗帜。德国国旗很好。波恩市的旗帜也很漂亮。上面有一只强壮的狮子和一个十字架。有人称它为小传奇法律。本周的“99%看不见”由萨鲁克·法拉瓦尔和我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了卢娜的支持，用创造力带来改变。它是旧金山本地公共广播电台KALW-91.7、旧金山美国建筑师学会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息，请访问网站。网址是 99%Invisible.org。哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦, 这太棒了。你 这个剧集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。